things continue to not go particularly
well for rudy giuliani
who i guess now we have to say is donald
trump's former lawyer
do we know for sure it seems at this
point he really isn't trump's lawyer
anymore uh youtube said yesterday that
they have suspended rudy giuliani
uh from the monetization program on
youtube which allows you to make money
from ads on your youtube channel the
david pakman show youtube channel
is part of that program and it is a
revenue source for us which has gone up
and down
we have also had our trials and
tribulations with that same
program why was rudy giuliani suspended
from that program
because he broke youtube's rules by
sharing election misinformation and
what's funny is
it's not just that rudy was sharing
election disinformation
he was creating election disinformation
we actually reviewed some of his
so-called podcast episodes on some
recent
uh live streams and uh he was not just
signal boosting he was actually a nexus
a catalyst of a lot of that information
the suspension from youtube's
monetization program for rudy is going
to last
at least 30 days and it started last
week according to youtube
now i think it's very important to
understand
again with this there are lots of people
who are saying
that's google google owns youtube
google's
anti-right-wing bias if you've been
watching this program for any period of
time
you know we've also had problems with
youtube monetization
early on when we were talking about
coronavirus
long before most of our colleagues were
taking it seriously
um we were fully demonetized on anything
relating to coronavirus
eventually youtube realized it seems
this coveted thing is going to be here
for a while
um so we are going to allow that content
to be monetized there was a while where
i wouldn't say the word coronavirus i
would say covid19 because there was a
period of time where
covet 19 wouldn't get you demonetized
but coronavirus would
there are times where the youtube
algorithm has
demonetized my content denouncing
extremism and white supremacy
because it couldn't distinguish it from
content promoting
extremism and white supremacy we had
adpocalypse in 2017
where my entire channel was deemed
dealing with issues too sensitive to
qualify
for any monetization and in april of
2017
we experienced a 99 or greater percent
loss of ad revenue there were days we
made
30 cents on youtube uh so anybody saying
that
youtube is only going after right-wing
channels
i am i am proof and evidence that that
has absolutely not been the case
youtube widely and proactively announced
you can't do the election disinformation
that content is not allowed
you can't allege that there was
widespread fraud
that changed the outcome of the 2020 or
really any presidential election
elections of discussions of election
results are allowed
content based around debunking false
claims of fraud
are fortunately allowed but spreading
the disinformation is not allowed now
rudy can appeal the suspension
he can reapply to the program in 30 days
if he removes the underlying
issues rudy giuliani did not respond to
a request for comment
from uh nbc so it's not a good week for
rudy
um demonetized on youtube sued for
defamation by dominion voting systems
for 1.3
billion dollars he says he will be
filing a countersuit
against dominion and that of course uh
remains to be seen i'm getting the sense
and i'm curious to hear what you think
that rudy is probably going to kind of
evaporate and and go off
into the ether with donald trump
completely silent in the week since he
left office
and with rudy um just taking
shots left and right and now getting
demonetized on youtube
i don't know that i don't know rudy's
financial situation
but my guess is he's not going to be
that worried about not making money off
of his weird youtube videos anymore and
that he's just
he's in his mid 70s my thought is he's
ready to retire and may just kind of
ride off into the sunset maybe i'm wrong
and we'll continue to follow it but
those alleging that this is evidence of
some uh
right-wing anti-right-wing bias from
youtube
the david pakman show youtube channel
and an experience in counterpoints to
that claim
one of our sponsors today is trivia star
a
free trivia game for mobile devices with
over 60 different
trivia categories including things i
know
you would love like geography history
science
many other great topics movies sports
food i've been having a bunch of fun
with it because
i as the player get to choose the
category so i'm only answering questions
on topics i'm interested in
there are over a thousand different
levels to progress to over ten thousand
different questions
which get harder over time so it gets
more and more interesting as you play
if you love trivia like i do i remember
the day's pre-virus of going out to
trivia at a bar
and you want a fun way to keep yourself
sharp check it out
really well designed game 4.9 star
rating and the number one rated mobile
trivia game in the world
it's totally free just go to the apple
and android app store
and search for trivia star